didn't get a chance to head on vacation for a
well needed rest as this Puck goes behind The
KES net trying to throw that one out in front
is ilen mcka qu hu's got to stick to it what a
season Hughes is having the captain for the
Canucks 50 assists that is third in the NHL
not for defenseman third in the league now
Vancouver stamps the shot through and that
one fortunate bounce for Carolina coov was holding
his he stayed on his feet beautifully now Bunning
with a chance and Demco has to make the save
as Michael Bunning Let One Go from the top of
the left Circle and now a steal by terrain
as he takes that puck away from pson he'll
flip it for martinook martinook looks behind
him waits for some help he'll drop it back
Tera ven with it out from Martin he scores
shorthanded and the Kane strike [Applause]
first the guy that was red hot in January what a
start for him here in Valentine's month terraining
lost the puck I think he knew that martinuk was
going to get to it first and then he follows up
for support on the half wall where he distributes
the puck on the power play and makes a terrific
decision from the same power play Spot shorthanded
gets it to Martin no he played his Western Hockey
League career for the Vancouver Giants in
British Columbia Kane's penalty killer still
with a little work to do shot gets through that
it'sit a crossbar Vancouver Zone Garland wastes
no time getting this Puck with Loft High to the
glove side it goes back to how good this penalty
kill has been since December now chance to clear
chap he get shot put right on sneaky little shot
that was thrown by Nils hoglander who's having a
career year in goals with 14 me will work this one
back in Co jov's had a d of tough looking shot
that he's made the saves for early on credited
with two shots are Vancouver but they've been
quality at a crossbar now a little chance there
from NES he chops one right on and J go with the
save now eronic plays it across for Hughes try
to dance away from bunny drop that off a low
shot and coov makes the save and and I didn't
know what that meant and that means that you're
styling and he was causing stylish chaos quick
shot chopped at slaving to the rebound now Co
kinami sent across Shay he'll Hammer that one
it'll take a funky bounce off the end boards
was appeared in 10 of the last 11 games for
the Carolina Hurricanes now a chance for chadfield
against his former team and that's steered Away by
Demco then looking for deflection out in front
good stick by lemu the orl will put this one
between the blue L he Hustle and have to stay on
now Vancouver with an opportunity developing shot
is handled as coov got the clove to it be sent
back in the hurricane Zone back to your point on
terrain and this is set out in front and Coach
jov with the answer on Dakota Joshua staying
on his feet like Archer Zer Once Upon a Time
and here going down but finding a way to still
move in the butterfly position mean he's still
challenging that's an unbelievable push now here
comes Vancouver Quinn Hughes he'll drop that a
little low shot put on Bounce goov makes the save
rebound. as the shot off the draw gets through
kochetov but he got enough of it to knock it off
Target he'll work this one back to the point
for Hughes a cross for besser besser's Drive
goes over the top of keto's net Vancouver keeps
it in Hughes at the blue line he looks for a shot
deflected they score Elias Lindholm out front
the shot from Hughes in a power play goal and
upset your old ones it's 1-1 now you think back
to his time as a Carolina hurricane he was an
excellent net front and pop out guy is a righty
in the power play that shot is headed well wide
Hughes just gets it by terrain and this Puck goes
from being quite a bit of Target to redirected to
beating Co ched COV on the blocker Justin Williams
another righty and right now Seth Jarvis you have
two jobs it's your net front but also to be
an outlet on the goal line and mck with it 10
seconds left in the period he'll just get this in
deep I don't mind the way this period has ended up
now Myers with a shot right on coov has to make
the save he'll lose it to Miller P Suter with it
Puck still rolling and Vancouver will play it back
shot by Cole save made by coov that shift happened
the morning in Ottawa and that was the turning
point he said guys you can point to that game
is being a big Turning Point Is AO with a chance
orlov will find Bunning kan's trying to mount a
little offense bunting find NES he goes Far Side
save made by dco or hamers one right on but not
many teams skate into this building and one with
65% of the draws like Vancouver did in the first
period just one another one now this chance comes
back to find Bluer he'll sweep one towards the net
now laery there is orov speak of the man who
had the game-winning goal now a little Drive
is deflected Away by ketov n to a Hughes he'll
play it back to the point aonic Patterson back
across the ice Hughes and that is going to be had
the Canuck scored there but you bet but you don't
break that's a long sh imp period but coming out
to the break or the last one on the ice he gets it
to stall there was a chance there Hughes looking
for deflection that shot misses everything and
it's picked up and worked right back to Hughes
settled down besser back for Hughes his shot no
score Quinn Hughes gets the shot and there's a
deflection out in front and it's a 2-1 another
tip for Elias Lindholm second power play goal of
the game he goes from being in the hashmark area
just a switch to create room between he and Miller
Hughes is the guy that got it to him on the first
one I mean this one was on target back for AO AO
waiting hanging on to the puod back up top Burns
a
[Music] we're tied at two in Carolina the
allstar delivers for The KES I love laser
tag as a kid this was a laser I think
Demco had a good look at it I really
think AO won the draw he had a battle to
beat Lyle that puck was on edge possibly
Jules didn't get out trying to block it
may have impacted deco's ability to track
it see talk about those first games back being
tough for the home team see if the canes can
take advantage but right now we're we're here oh
boy as this Puck bounces on ketov rebound they
score JT Miller to the loose Puck and sweeps
it into the yawning cage and four minutes into
the third the Canucks have a 3-2 lead on the
glass Anything Can Happen Myers gaps up puts
it on the glass and Coach edop is not only a
no man's land and he's been good tonight but
I didn't like the fact he's caught get yourself
back to the net he's just sort of rela he relaxed
question is as this is happening and he's trying
to play it with one hand does that bump Yeah Boy
sudor some players defenseman it's getting
it through quickly is their move for orof
it's the shake and bank as he did on his goal
against Arizona NES with it Bei and dco with
the save of the game right now for Vancouver
Cod KMI back with it he'll 7 seconds left Cod
KMI with it taking a look 4 seconds left trying
to put it out in front it comes into the corner
and the horn will go and Vancouver will hang
on and they'll best the GS here tonight 3-2